david frost has today told the eu to
take britain seriously in talks over
a future trade deal time to reach an
agreement is fast running out but lord
frost says that unlike theresa may's
government
his team will not blink first well to
discuss that
and much more we're joined by the former
shadow home secretary labour's dan
abbott thank you very much for being
on the show this morning miss abbott i
just want to start
on brexit you of course were very strong
campaigner for remain you'll have seen
david frost's words about saying the uk
won't blink first
in the negotiations do you think the
chances
of leaving without a trade deal are
going up
i think there's a very real danger
that we will leave without a proper deal
and that could be disastrous in many
ways
we've spent the past weeks talking about
channel crossings you're not going to be
able to act effectively
against with migrants crossing the
channel
once you come out of the eu and we don't
have the cooperation or we don't have
the access
to databases coming out without a deal
would be detrimental in so many ways
you say that we won't be able to act on
migrant crossings
effectively without being in the eu but
this has been going on for years and we
haven't been
able to act effectively on it for years
does this not mean that perhaps
we need to just shift our policy when it
comes to
dealing with refugees dealing with
migrants many people would say for
example that we need to take a tougher
line on people trying to cross
from calais and actually look at people
in refugee camps families who may not
have the money
to get to cali in the first place and
aren't supporting people smugglers
well certainly we should have more safe
and legal routes but what i'm saying is
without access to criminal databases
actually cracking down on the criminal
smuggling gangs
will be more difficult and with no deal
we will not have
access to those databases we won't have
the cooperation with europol
but we're in the eu we've had the
cooperation of europe and we still
haven't
managed to crack it so far
there's such a thing as things getting
worse without access to databases and
the cooperation of europol
things could get worse okay
now on friday night um climate change
protesters
extinction rebellion targeted the
printing presses of newspapers including
the sunday times the times the sun the
sun on sunday
and the telegraph as well the mail do
you have sympathy
with what they were trying to do
i think it's important to remind
ourselves is that direct
action which is what those actions were
is actually legal we also saw over the
weekend
blockading of the port of dover
by far-right and anti-immigrant
activists like
britain first and the edl these
tactics are legal whatever we think of
the people practicing them
so what do you think of the tactics of
extinction rebellion uh the labour mp
don butler tweeted yesterday before
deleting the tweet
bravo extinction rebellion excellent
work did she get it right the first time
in your view
i can repeat what i've said these are
legal tactics
and we don't want to talk as if it's not
illegal to take direct action
because direct action has been legal
since the time of the suffragettes
i mean there were reports this morning
that the government is looking at
reclassifying extinction rebellion as an
organized crime group
do you think that would be a good move
that would be ridiculous
they're not criminals they are
protesters and activists
in the tradition of the suffragettes and
the hunger marchers
of the 1930s i mean you're saying that
they're in the tradition of the
suffragettes and the hunger marches i
mean
some people listening to you may think
that this is exactly the kind of
worrying impact of cancer culture that
some people are concerned about trying
to shut down voices that you disagree
with
trying to stop the free press and
actually
that you should be taking a much tougher
line on extinction rebellion
i'm taking a tough line of people's
freedoms under law
we don't want to in the covered era move
into a time when people's freedoms are
being clamped down
on direct action is a legal tactic
it was used by the far right in dover
this weekend and the same papers
complaining about blockades were not
complaining about anti-immigrant
activists blockading dover and actually
blockading ports
is potentially far more damaging to the
british economy
than what happened at the newspaper
plants um i just want to read
labour's response to extinction
rebellion which was a free press is
vital for our democracy
people have the right to read the
newspapers they want stopping them from
being distributed and printers from
doing their jobs
is wrong do you agree with the official
labor line on this then
i think it's right that people do
have the right to read what newspapers
are saying that articles commentary and
so on
fortunately every single word that these
newspapers are saying
is available online it's interesting
because um
on extinction rebellion and also on
other issues as well it feels as if
the labour party undercares dama have
been reluctant to take a
strong position in the culture war if
you like they've been reluctant to
criticize too strongly on either side it
feels as if the party has
reshifted i guess from the left to the
center
are you comfortable with the way that
the labour party is going under kirsten
i don't think kirsten would say he's
shifted from the left one of the things
he said after he was elected as leader
that it was important to hold on to our
values
and it was important not to abandon
our newfound radicalism he said that the
case
for a strong radical labour party
is as important as ever so i don't think
that stir karma would say
islam would say that we've shifted to
the right
it sounds a little bit like we're trying
to remind kirstama
about some of the things that he said in
the past do you think that he
was happy to appear more left-wing more
pro-corbyn during the leadership
election to try and get votes
you may say that i couldn't possibly
comment all i'm telling you is on the
record
kia stammer has been very clear that we
shouldn't
abandon the radicalism we found in the
corbyn era
okay even though it led the party to the
worst defeat since 1935
i'm only telling you what kierstarma
said
okay now it's the first interview that
i've done with you since the
black lives matter protests um as a
former
shadow home secretary also of course the
first female black mp
i'm interested in what you think about
the police
in this country do you think that there
is a problem with racism in the police
well the figures don't lie black people
are disproportionately
likely to be stopped and searched black
people
are disproportionately likely to have
handcuffs
used on them even under the covered
legislation
black people were disproportionately
likely to have fines
applied to them so it does appear if you
look at the figures
that black people are disproportionately
affected by the way the criminal justice
system operates of course my colleague
david lammy
talked about this in relation to the
courts do you think that we need to
re-look at the policy on stop and search
as a result of that
well i think the tourists could do worse
than revisit
some of the the policies that theresa
may was trying to bring forward theresa
may
actually don't agree with a lot of
things but she understood
that stop research was potentially
a problem for relationships between
young people and the police nothing
minority communities in the police
so the tories could revisit her
efforts to bring down the level of
non-evidence-based stop research of
course we all agree
with evidence based on search but it's
non-evident stop and such
random stop research which causes
problems
uh and just finally while i've got you
the former labour home secretary jackie
smith
has been unveiled as one of the latest
signings on strictly com dancing i've
got to ask if they ever approach you
about it would you do it
if they did they have and i turned them
down
i couldn't possibly do it i think
jackie's very brave
how come you felt you couldn't possibly
do it
because you'd be surprised to know i'm
not someone with natural rhythm
and i didn't want it exposed to millions
of television viewers
that seems like a very fair response to
me uh diane abbott thank you very much
for being on the programme this morning
thank you